Parents-- here's all the evidence that you need that TV is bad for kids. Especially public TV. When Sean was 14, he loved watching those British TV shows that are always running on PBS. Masterpiece Theatre, Doctor Who.
父母们——这就是你们所需要的，证明电视对孩子有害的全部证据。尤其是公共电视。肖恩14岁时，非常喜欢看那些在公共电视网（PBS）上常年播出的英剧。比如《杰作剧场》、《神秘博士》。
And then there was this show that I would stay up really late and watch, and tape, and watch over and over again the tapes, called Dempsey & Makepeace. Which was about an American detective who went to London because he had been set up at home. And he was teamed up with a woman, who was this aristocrat named Lady Harriet Makepeace. And I was really on her side, I thought, she's got it going on.
还有一部剧，我会熬夜看，录下来，然后一遍又一遍地看录像带，叫《登普西和梅克皮斯》。讲的是一个美国侦探因为在家乡被陷害而去了伦敦。他与一位名叫哈里特·梅克皮斯夫人的贵族女性搭档。我当时真的很支持她，我觉得，她真是太厉害了。
You looked down on the American.
你瞧不起那个美国人。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
What Sean liked about Lady Harriet Makepeace and all the other Brits on TV was their aloofness. How they seemed above it all, how they looked down on Americans, which Sean did also. Convinced there must be something wrong with the nation that produced jocks and bullies who harassed him at school. And sometimes, joking around with his friends, he would talk with a British accent.
肖恩喜欢哈里特·梅克皮斯夫人和电视上其他英国人的地方，就是他们的冷漠。他们看起来高高在上，看不起美国人，肖恩也一样。他确信那个制造了在学校里欺负、骚扰他的运动员和恶霸的国家肯定出了什么问题。有时，在和朋友开玩笑时，他会用英国口音说话。
And then it was just something that spiraled out of control. I know that eventually, I was just using an English accent literally from waking to sleeping. Morning, noon, and night.
然后，这就变得一发不可收拾了。我知道最终，我从起床到睡觉真的都在用英国口音。从早到晚，一直如此。
Sean spoke with a British accent from the time he was 14 until he was 16. And at some point, his mother took him to see a psychiatrist.
肖恩从14岁到16岁一直说着英国口音。有一次，他母亲带他去看心理医生。
He was just really, he must-- I don't know the different schools of psychology, but he was really very confrontive. And he was like, well, you've got to stop doing this, he said, because you're not British. And my mom just sort of sat over next to me, and she sort of went, yeah, to agree with him. And to sort of help him in showing me this.
他真的很，他必须——我不了解不同的心理学流派，但他确实非常爱争辩。他说，你得停止这样做，因为你不是英国人。我妈妈就坐在我旁边，她有点像，是的，同意他的观点。并试图帮他向我证明这一点。
Sean was furious. He had an impulse to lecture the guy on how, in fact, he was British. And the only problem with that was, A, he knew very well that he was not, and B, his mother was sitting right there. She was sure to contradict him. It all just seemed impossible.
肖恩非常愤怒。他有一种冲动，想教训那个家伙，告诉他其实自己就是英国人。唯一的问题是，第一，他很清楚自己不是，第二，他妈妈就坐在那里。她肯定会反驳他。这一切似乎都不可能。
Because that's what I was thinking. Like, there has to be a way that I could be British still.
因为我当时就是那么想的。就像，一定有办法让我还是英国人。
There must be a way that this is true, somehow.
一定有办法让这是真的，以某种方式。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，没错。
Well today on our radio program, stories of people to tell a lie, and they get to the point where they believe the lie more than anyone else does. In other words, stories of people pulling hoaxes on themselves. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
今天在我们的广播节目中，讲述的是人们撒谎，直到他们自己比任何人都更相信这个谎言的故事。换句话说，关于人们对自己进行欺骗的故事。这里是来自WBEZ芝加哥和国际公共广播电台的《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Act one of our program today, The Sun Never Sets On The Moosewood Restaurant, in which two young men, both from small towns, try on new identities, false identities, and what they have to do to keep the lies going. Act two, Conning The Con Men. Nancy Updike reports on a federal sting operation and how it caught con men by setting up a con of its own. Act three, Outperforming the Performers. A girl gets her big break on Broadway by going into a coma. Stay with us.
今天节目的第一幕，《太阳永不落下——穆斯伍德餐厅》，讲述两个来自小镇的年轻人尝试新身份、假身份，以及他们为了维持谎言所做的一切。第二幕，《欺骗骗子》。南希·厄普代克报道了一次联邦钓鱼执法，以及他们如何通过设下骗局来抓捕骗子。第三幕，《超越表演者》。一个女孩通过装昏迷在百老汇获得了大突破。请继续收听。
Act one, The Sun Never Sets on the Moosewood Restaurant. This is the story of two young people who, for a period in their lives, in their search to figure out who they were, pretended to be people who they were not. We'll hear from Sean Cole and Joel Lovell, starting with Sean. He grew up in a small town in Massachusetts, a town that was approximately 3,350 miles from London.
第一幕，《太阳永不落下——穆斯伍德餐厅》。这是一个关于两个年轻人的故事，他们在人生的某个阶段，在寻找自我的过程中，假装成了别人。我们将听到肖恩·科尔和乔尔·洛弗尔的故事，从肖恩开始。他在马萨诸塞州的一个小镇长大，那个小镇距离伦敦大约3350英里。
It was second nature. It was first nature. To this day I have trouble saying, oh, I faked an accent for two years. I mean, I had an accent for two years.
这是第二天性。这是第一天性。直到今天，我说“哦，我装了两年口音”都很困难。我的意思是，我确实有两年的口音。
Sean, could I just ask you to take a deep breath and describe for me what you had for lunch today, or perhaps for breakfast this morning, in as close to the accent that you can remember.
肖恩，我能请你深呼吸一下，用你所能记住的最接近那种口音，描述一下你今天午餐吃了什么，或者今天早餐吃了什么吗。
As close I can. OK. I'm going to take a sip of water here. Well, Ira, I had a salad. I had it at the Boston House of Pancakes-- er, Pizza, rather.
尽我所能。好的。我先喝口水。嗯，艾拉，我吃了沙拉。是在波士顿煎饼屋——哦，不，是比萨店吃的。
What was the beverage?
喝了什么饮料？
It was a Snapple, just lemon-flavored. I don't really like the peach.
是Snapple，柠檬味的。我不太喜欢桃子味的。
Joel Lovell's story began when he left the working class town where he grew up, in upstate New York. His parents owned a liquor store in a small town. He was the first member of his family to go to college, and it was an especially big deal because he got into an Ivy League school, Cornell.
乔尔·洛弗尔的故事始于他离开他长大的工薪阶层小镇，前往纽约州北部。他的父母在小镇上开了一家酒铺。他是家里第一个上大学的人，这尤其了不起，因为他考上了常春藤盟校——康奈尔大学。
It was one of those first days of college, you know, when to spend a lot of time-- everybody kind of moves in hordes, and you spend a lot of time in each other's dorm rooms. And there were about, oh, I don't know, 10 or 11 of us in this one guy's room. And we were just like sitting around, eating pizza and talking. And people were talking about where they were from and what their parents did, stuff like that. And there was one guy whose dad was a doctor for the Knicks. There was another guy whose father was an elected representative from New York State. And then this other guy whose father was on the World Court. Literally was a member of the World Court.
那是大学开学的第一天，你知道，每个人都聚在一起，你在彼此的宿舍里花了很多时间。那个人的房间里大概有，哦，我不知道，10或11个人。我们只是坐在一起，吃比萨，聊天。大家在聊家乡在哪，父母做什么工作之类的。其中一个人父亲是尼克斯队的医生。另一个人父亲是纽约州的民选代表。还有一个人的父亲在国际法院。真的是国际法院的成员。
Oh, my.
哦，天哪。
And so it suddenly seemed like this incredibly impressive group to me. And they seemed sort of worldly in ways that was just beyond my wildest imagination. And worldly beyond what I am now, frankly.
所以这对我来说突然看起来是一个极其令人印象深刻的群体。他们似乎以某种方式表现得世故，超出了我最疯狂的想象。老实说，甚至比我现在还要世故。
And I remember sitting there at the time thinking, oh my God, I'm so out of my league here. And then, completely unplanned, I suddenly said, as a slice of pizza was passed to me, this pizza with sausage on top of it. I said, I can't take that because my parents are vegetarians. And then everybody in the room sort of turned and looked at me. Because it wasn't even as if I said well, I'm a vegetarian. But I said, my parents are vegetarians. And there's a sort of puzzled look on everybody in the room. And I said well, and I am too. I've never eaten meat. I'm not entirely-- well, I mean, I have some ideas now about why I said that. But at the time I had no idea what I was saying. It was like suddenly I'd become possessed. And I had to think of something to say about myself that seemed interesting. And vegetarianism was the thing that I chose.
我记得当时坐在那里想，天哪，我和他们根本不是一个层次的。然后，完全没经过计划，当一块比萨递给我时，上面有香肠，我突然说：我不能吃那个，因为我父母是素食者。然后房间里每个人都转头看着我。因为那甚至不是我说了“我是素食者”。但我说了，“我父母是素食者”。房间里每个人都露出了困惑的表情。我说，嗯，我也是。我从来没吃过肉。我不是完全——好吧，我的意思是，我现在对为什么那么说有一些想法。但当时我根本不知道自己在说什么。就像突然被附体了一样。我必须想出一些关于自己的、看起来很有趣的话题。于是我选择了素食主义。
Now, did you tell people that you were actually from England?
那么，你有没有告诉别人你其实来自英国？
No, no. Never that I was from Britain. But in a way, that I was British, you know. There was a real distinction there for me. Like I'd taken it on. Like I was culturally British now.
没有，没有。从来没说过我来自英国。但在某种程度上，我就是英国人，你知道。对我来说，这之间有真正的区别。就像我已经接受了它。就像我在文化上已经是英国人了。
Well, I think what it was is, I think I did some sort of calculus that took like an nanosecond in my head. And I thought, I can't actually lie about what my parents do. But I think the connections that I was making were this. That somehow, because I was from this town in the sticks, if my folks were vegetarians, then the whole history that that suggested was that they were sort of these kind of leftist academic radicals who had sort of dropped out of society and gone back to the land. And I was living in this bumpkin town in upstate New York, and my folks were living some sort of life that was driven by their political philosophy, rather than I was just a guy who grew up in upstate New York.
嗯，我想原因在于，我在脑子里做了一些计算，大概花了一纳秒。我想，关于我父母是做什么的，我不能撒谎。但我当时的联想是这样的：因为我来自那个乡下的偏远小镇，如果我父母是素食者，那么这背后的全部历史就意味着他们是那种左翼学术激进分子，退出了社会，回归了田园。而我当时住在纽约州北部那个土气的镇子上，我父母过的是一种由其政治哲学驱动的生活，而不是我只是一个在纽约州北部成长起来的普通家伙。
I did the old kid thing of wishing that my real British parents would come and tell me I was adopted and take me back to London.
我做了那种老套的孩子的行为，希望我真正的英国父母会出现，告诉我我是被领养的，然后带我回伦敦。
So I'm sitting there in the room and all these guys are looking at me. And they're like, dude, what do you eat? And suddenly I realized, in that moment, how little I knew about vegetarianism. I kind of tried to be real vague about it. You know, we eat salads and lentils. I remember saying lentils a lot.
所以我坐在房间里，所有那些家伙都看着我。他们说，老兄，你吃什么？在那一刻，我突然意识到我对素食主义了解得太少了。我试图对此说得很模糊。你知道，我们吃沙拉和小扁豆。我记得我经常说小扁豆。
And there was a gap, certainly, in my education. Because I would be using words that Americans just don't use. I would, instead of saying drug store, I would say chemist. Or I would try my best to remember to say bonnet instead of hood, or boot instead of trunk. But I often couldn't.
而且我的教育肯定有断层。因为我会使用美国人根本不用的词。我会说“药剂师”（chemist）而不是“药店”（drug store）。或者我会尽力记住说“引擎盖”（bonnet）而不是“车前盖”（hood），说“后备箱”（boot）而不是“行李箱”（trunk）。但我经常记不住。
On the meal plan I ended up eating a lot of big piles of iceberg lettuce. And chickpeas.
在学校用餐计划里，我最后吃了很多大堆的冰山生菜。还有鹰嘴豆。
And during that time, would you find yourself sneaking to go to get meat somewhere?
那段时间，你会不会发现自己偷偷溜出去买肉吃？
Yeah, definitely. At first I would go really far from campus in order to have a BLT. There's this diner downtown in Ithaca, and it felt incredibly illicit. I'd be sitting there and I'd have some reading material or something with me, and I'd be the lonely guy in my booth. And I would order the BLT and I would watch it coming from across the room, with its toothpick in the top of it. And a side of French fries with this meat gravy on top. And when it landed on the table it would just seem like this incredibly wonderful moment. When you're doing something just totally unlike what anybody would expect of you.
会，绝对会。起初，我会走离校园很远的地方去吃BLT三明治。伊萨卡市中心有一家餐馆，那感觉极其非法。我会坐在那里，带点阅读材料什么的，我会是卡座里孤独的家伙。我会点BLT，看着它从房间另一头送过来，上面插着牙签。还有一份配着肉汁的炸薯条。当它落到桌子上时，那简直是一个极其美妙的时刻。当你做的事情完全出乎所有人的意料时。
I was a nobody. I was living in an extremely small, kind of rural town, in the middle of nowhere. I guess, in a way, this was my way of travelling. And of being somebody. And sort of achieving an identity. Which I guess I didn't feel like I had. I didn't feel like-- I'm just sort of realizing this now-- but I guess I didn't feel as though I had anything that made me up.
我是一个无名小卒。我住在一个极小的、乡村化的、偏僻的小镇上。我想，在某种程度上，这就是我旅行和成为某人的方式。以及获得某种身份认同。我想我当时觉得自己并没有这些。我不觉得——我只是现在才意识到这一点——但我猜我不觉得我有什么能构成我的东西。
I mean, what I realized fairly quickly is that if this is going to be believable, I actually have to believe in it. But I also began to, not only believe, but really sort of take on as my persona, all the stuff that I imagined was associated with vegetarianism.
我的意思是，我很快意识到，如果这要让人相信，我必须真的相信它。但我也开始，不仅是相信，而是真正地将我所想象的与素食主义相关的一切，作为我的人格呈现出来。
Like what?
比如什么？
Well, certain political convictions, and ways of dress.
嗯，某些政治信念，还有着装方式。
I wore ripped jeans and I wore combat boots. But I also wore a kind of stage jacket that you would see in a community theater production of Hamlet.
我穿破洞牛仔裤和战斗靴。但我也穿一种舞台夹克，你会在社区剧院制作的《哈姆雷特》中看到的那种。
Yeah, I bought sandals. I very specifically remember going down to this thrift store in downtown Ithaca and buying a pair of fatigue shorts, which just seemed like I might as well have been Che Guevara at that point. As far I was concerned I was a dangerous leftist.
是的，我买了凉鞋。我非常清楚地记得去伊萨卡市中心的一家旧货店，买了一件军装短裤，在那一刻，我感觉自己简直就像切·格瓦拉。就我而言，我是一个危险的左翼分子。
Did you, at any point during this, find yourself in the following argument where you would say, I've never had a hamburger, and somebody would insist, oh, you must have had meat some point. And then you had to argue your side.
在你经历这段时间的任何时候，有没有遇到过这样的争论：你说“我从来没吃过汉堡”，而别人坚持说“哦，你肯定在某个时候吃过肉”。然后你不得不为自己辩解。
Yeah, definitely. It wasn't pretty. And of course, I had grown up-- just to put this in context for a second, if you don't mind. I mean, not only had I had hundreds of hamburgers, and gone to the McDonald's drive through hundreds of times, but the counter point situation that I always think about when I remember this time was that, when I was a senior in high school, my family, for time saving reasons, decided that a great thing to do would be to go to Arby's Roast Beef. I don't know if you have those out in Chicago, I think they're countrywide.
是的，绝对有。那场面可不好看。当然，我是在——为了给这加个背景，如果你不介意的话。我的意思是，我不仅吃过几百个汉堡，去过几百次麦当劳的免下车窗口，而且我总是回想起那个反面例子：当我高三时，为了省时间，家里决定去吃Arby's烤牛肉三明治。我不知道你们芝加哥有没有，我觉得它们遍布全国。
So my dad and I would go to Arby's, on say, a Thursday afternoon or something. Or after I got out of school. And we would go in there and we would buy 48 Arby's roast beef sandwiches. And they would put them in this cardboard box. And we would bring home this giant box full of those tin foil covered Arby's roast beef sandwiches, and we would stuff them in our freezer. We would freeze the Arby's roast beef sandwiches and then we would have them there.
所以我爸和我会在比如周四下午什么的去Arby's。或者放学后。我们会进去买48个Arby's烤牛肉三明治。他们会把它们装在这个纸箱子里。我们会把装满锡纸包裹的Arby's烤牛肉三明治的巨型箱子带回家，然后塞进冷冻室。我们会冷冻那些三明治，然后随时吃。
Buns and all?
连面包一起？
Buns and all, yeah. And so we would have them there as ready made snacks whenever we might want one. I mean, that's the kind of meat eating that my family was engaged in.
连面包一起，是的。所以我们随时想吃就有现成的点心。我的意思是，这就是我家人参与的那种吃肉方式。
The other things was that I had these run ins with doubting my British identity,
另一件事是，我会对我的英国身份产生怀疑。
Oh really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah, as though it were slipping away. And I would really go nuts at that point. And there was one time it happened at home. I was at home, and I was like, oh my god, I have to do something. I have to affirm my devotion. I opened up the window and I psyched myself to do it. I was just like, oh man, if I don't do this, it won't come back. And I opened up the window, and then I screamed-- this is in the middle of the night, or, ten at night. And I screamed I love England, of course in a British accent, outside the window.
是的，好像它正在溜走。在那一刻，我会彻底崩溃。有一次是在家里发生的。我在家里，心想，天哪，我必须做点什么。我必须确认我的忠诚。我打开窗户，给自己打气，准备去做。我就想，天哪，如果我不这样做，它就不会回来了。我打开窗户，然后尖叫——这是在大半夜，或者晚上十点。我冲着窗外尖叫“我爱英国”，当然是用英国口音。
And then you felt better? You felt like you had reasserted yourself?
然后你感觉好些了吗？你觉得你重新确立了自己？
I felt like I had done something, at least.
我觉得至少我做了一些事情。
For England.
为了英国。
Yeah. I had fortified my Britishness.
是的。我巩固了我的英国属性。
I would find myself in these conversations where people were saying, you've never had a McDonald's hamburger. What kind of American, 18 year old American, has never had a hamburger from McDonald's?
我经常发现自己陷入这样的对话：人们说“你从来没吃过麦当劳汉堡。一个18岁的美国人怎么可能从来没吃过麦当劳的汉堡？”
Quite a legitimate question, I would add.
这是一个非常合理的问题，我要补充一点。
Absolutely, absolutely. And I would say, yeah, you know. I've just never had one, they scare me. And I would talk about the ways-- and I would make up these stories about how I'd come close a couple of times. How a friend of mine in high school had bought me a Big Mac and there I was, sitting on the front seat of his car, and I almost ate it, and then couldn't bring myself to do it. So there was all the drama that I lied about.
当然，当然。我会说，是的，你知道。我只是从来没吃过，它们让我害怕。我会谈论——我会编造一些故事，讲我曾经有几次差点就吃了。讲我高中时的一个朋友给我买了个巨无霸，我就坐在他车的前座上，差点就吃了，结果还是没能下得去口。所以，我撒了谎，制造了所有的戏剧性。
My mom and Dad came down to visit for parents' weekend, and they were really proud that I was going there, and really excited to come down. And they came down to visit.
我的爸妈来参加父母周末，他们为我上这所学校感到非常自豪，非常兴奋地赶来。他们来探望我。
And really proud because you were the first generation to go to college, you made it into this Ivy League school, it was a big, big deal.
而且非常自豪，因为你是家里第一代上大学的人，你考进了这所常春藤名校，这真的是件大事。
Right, exactly. Exactly. And so they drove down from Camillus, which is about between an hour and an hour and a half, they came down. And in that week leading up to parents' weekend, everybody's talking about their parents coming, and everybody's making reservations at restaurants, where to eat on Saturday night, and everybody's sort of planning on taking their parents to the football game on Saturday during the day. And it suddenly occurred to me, this real panic set it, that my parents would come down, and we would go to a football game and my dad would buy a hot dog. And somebody across the field would see Mr. Lovell eating a hot dog. And then, of course, the cat would be out of the bag.
对，没错。没错。所以他们从卡米勒斯开车过来，大概是一个到两个半小时的车程，他们赶来了。在那个父母周末到来前的星期里，每个人都在谈论他们的父母要来，都在预订餐馆，周六晚上去哪吃，每个人都在计划周六白天带父母去看橄榄球比赛。我突然产生了一种真正的恐慌，担心我的父母过来，我们去看球赛，我爸会去买热狗。球场对面有人会看到洛弗尔先生在吃热狗。那么，谎言当然就会穿帮了。
And so I thought, I've got to make a reservation at a restaurant. At someplace either, A, where nobody else's parents will be, or at a vegetarian restaurant. And so what I did was make a reservation at the Moosewood Restaurant, which is in Ithaca. There's the Moosewood cookbooks that are out.
所以我心想，我得在餐馆订个位。去一个要么，A，没有别人父母去的地方，或者是一家素食餐馆。所以我做的是在伊萨卡的穆斯伍德餐厅订了位。那边有穆斯伍德的烹饪书出版。
Vegetarian cookbooks.
素食烹饪书。
Exactly, yeah. And it's this nice little vegetarian restaurant in Ithaca, and a slightly famous place. But then we got there. And I remember sitting down at the table in the Moosewood, and the bowls are these kind of carved wooden bowls, and everything about it feels like a vegetarian restaurant.
没错，是的。这是伊萨卡一家不错的小型素食餐馆，稍微有点名气。但我们到了那里。我记得坐在穆斯伍德的桌边，碗是那种木雕碗，关于它的一切都感觉像是一家素食餐厅。
And not just a vegetarian restaurant, but kind of a cartoon of a vegetarian restaurant.
而且不仅仅是一家素食餐厅，更像是一种素食餐厅的漫画版本。
Exactly. Exactly. And I was looking at my parents across the table, and they were dressed up and they were excited to be coming down, and I could tell my dad was sitting there and sort of perusing the menu and thinking, well, maybe this lentil salad will be good. Or whatever. And I could he was sitting there thinking geeze, I just drove an hour and a half, all I want is a steak, and a baked potato, and a beer. And there I was bringing them here.
没错。没错。我看着桌子对面的父母，他们盛装打扮，为能来这里感到兴奋，我可以看出我爸坐在那里，仔细浏览菜单，心想，好吧，也许这个小扁豆沙拉会不错。或者别的什么。我可以看出他坐在那儿心想，天哪，我刚开了个把小时的车，我只想吃块牛排，一个烤土豆，喝杯啤酒。而我却带他们来了这里。
But they were so game about it. They were so willing to go along with it because, for some reason, they thought I really wanted to bring them there. And I just thought, geeze, you know, these people, my parents, have really given up a lot for me to come there. I mean, financially they were really stretching themselves, and we were taking out all sorts of loans, and all of those things that people do in order to go to college. They never complained once about doing it. They just wanted to come down and see me there and feel all proud that I was there, and I was sort of hiding them out in this vegetarian restaurant. And I felt so bad about it afterwards.
但他们真的很配合。他们非常愿意顺着我来，因为出于某种原因，他们以为我真的很想带他们来这里。我心想，天哪，你知道，这些人，我的父母，真的为了让我来这里付出了很多。我的意思是，在经济上他们真的很吃力，我们贷了各种款，所有那些人们为了上大学而做的事情。他们从没抱怨过一次。他们只是想来看看我，为我在那里感到自豪，而我却把他们藏在了一家素食餐馆里。事后我感到非常难过。
And they never once complained. They went home, and I sort of imagine them stopping at a Hardy's just outside of Ithaca, getting a burger as soon as they say goodbye. But after that I just thought geeze, I've got to find some way to come clean about this.
他们一次也没抱怨过。他们回家了，我甚至想象他们在伊萨卡郊外停在哈迪餐厅，刚道别就买了个汉堡吃。但那之后我心想，天哪，我必须找个办法坦白这件事。
I mean, is it OK if your child decides to express themself in an alternate personality for a period of two years.
我的意思是，如果你的孩子决定在两年的时间里以另一种人格来表达自己，这可以吗？
I think there's-- it's funny, I never thought I would say this-- but I think there's nothing wrong with that. I never thought I would say it because I wish that I hadn't done it now. But maybe I learned something from doing it. I mean, I think that that is par for the course. Now I think that's part of growing up.
我想这里有——这很有趣，我从没想过我会这么说——但我认为这没什么错。我从没想过我会这么说，因为我现在希望我当时没这么做。但也许我在这样做中学到了一些东西。我的意思是，我认为这很正常。现在我认为这是成长的一部分。
I think it was probably necessary for me at that time in my life.
我想这对我人生的那个阶段来说可能是必要的。
Because it gave you more confidence.
因为它给了你更多的自信。
Yeah, and there was some ridge that that this allowed me to cross.
是的，这让我跨越了某种鸿沟。
Joel Lovell and Sean Cole. Joel Lovell is a writer in New York City.
乔尔·洛弗尔和肖恩·科尔。乔尔·洛弗尔是纽约市的一名作家。
Sean Cole works in public radio in Boston.
肖恩·科尔在波士顿从事公共广播工作。
[MUSIC - "MEAT" BY NOISE ADDICT]
[音乐 - 噪音成瘾者的《肉》]
Act two, Conning the Con Men. The American legal system, for the most part, does not uphold the principle of eye for an eye. If you steal somebody's car, the police do not steal your car in return. If they catch you selling marijuana, they do not sell marijuana to you as your punishment. But if you're in the business of running scams, authorities catch you by running a scam on you. This is the story of a con man who made millions by fooling people over the phone, until he was the one who got fooled. Nancy Updike reports.
第二幕，《欺骗骗子》。美国法律体系在很大程度上并不坚持“以眼还眼”的原则。如果你偷了别人的车，警察不会反过来偷你的车。如果你被抓到卖大麻，他们不会以卖大麻给你作为惩罚。但如果你是做诈骗生意的，当局抓你的方式就是对你进行诈骗。这是一个骗子通过电话愚弄人们赚了数百万美元，直到他自己被愚弄的故事。南希·厄普代克报道。
The guy's name is David Diamond. That's his actual name. He was one of the most successful salesman in one of the longest running telemarketing scams in Los Angeles history.
这个人的名字叫大卫·戴安德。那是他的真名。他是洛杉矶历史上最持久的电话诈骗案之一中最成功的推销员。
David Diamond was a salesman at a boiler room.
大卫·戴安德是某电话中心的一名推销员。
This is Dale Sekovich. He's been a Federal Trade Commission investigator for 29 years. He's the one who busted Diamond.
这是戴尔·塞科维奇。他担任联邦贸易委员会调查员已经29年了。正是他抓获了戴安德。
He was living in a very expensive home up in the hills of Woodland Hills. He drove a custom Porsche Carrera that he had shipped over here by airplane from Germany from the factory. They lived very high on the hog.
他住在伍德兰希尔斯山上一个非常昂贵的家里。他开着一辆定制的保时捷卡雷拉，那是他从德国工厂空运过来的。他们的生活极其奢侈。
David Diamond was just one of a whole bunch of guys making money hand over fist in an operation in southern California that was basically running the same scam over and over, under different names, for seven years. It was an investment scheme. Give us your money and we'll put it into this great 900 number business, or this online shopping network, or this hot new internet service provider. Needless to say, no one ever made a dime, except the people running the scam who cleared $40 million.
大卫·戴安德只是在南加州经营的一大批赚取暴利的人之一，该运营七年来基本上是在不同名称下反复进行同样的骗局。这是一个投资计划。给我们钱，我们会把它投入到这个很棒的900电话业务，或者是这个在线购物网络，或者这个热门的新互联网服务提供商中。不用说，除了运营骗局的人捞到了4000万美元之外，从来没有人赚过一分钱。
Since Diamond was one of the operation's top salesmen, he made $2 million in commissions in just four years on the job. He got 30% of whatever he talked a person into investing. That means he personally conned people out of more than $6 million. The FTC caught Diamond and the others in the operation essentially by conning the con men. They had volunteers pose as dupes and record their phone calls. Because the FTC brought a case against the operation Diamond worked in, some of those recordings are now part of the public record. I got Dale Sekovich to listen to the tapes with me, and talk about David Diamond and the FBI volunteer who caught him.
由于戴安德是该运营中最顶尖的推销员之一，他仅仅用了四年时间就在工作中获得了200万美元的佣金。他拿走了他劝说人们投资金额的30%。这意味着他个人从人们手中诈骗了超过600万美元。联邦贸易委员会抓获戴安德和运营中的其他人，本质上是通过欺骗这些骗子。他们让志愿者伪装成受骗者并录下他们的通话。由于联邦贸易委员会对戴安德工作的运营提起了诉讼，其中一些录音现在已成为公共记录的一部分。我让戴尔·塞科维奇和我一起听这些录音，并谈谈大卫·戴安德以及抓获他的联邦调查局志愿者。
The woman on the tape, I can't tell you her real name, but she uses the alias of Marge. She assumed the identity of a person who is named Marge. Marge was a real person who we in law enforcement and who people in the telemarketing business refer to as a mooch. A mooch is someone who will essentially buy anything from anybody who calls her on the telephone. In fact she did, over a number of years. She spent hundreds of thousands of dollars--
录音里的那个女人，我不能告诉你她的真名，但她用了马吉这个化名。她假设了马吉这个人的身份。马吉是一个真实的人，我们执法人员和电话营销行业的人称之为“冤大头”。冤大头是指那些本质上会从任何打电话给她的人那里买任何东西的人。事实上，她确实在几年内这么做了。她花费了数十万美元——
The real Marge.
真正的马吉。
The real Marge spent hundreds of thousands of dollars on bogus prize promotions, investments, gold coins, you name it. So the FBI went to Marge and said, we really think that we need to take your telephone number away from you, because it's being used to ruin your life. So once Marge agreed to that, her telephone number was installed in the home of an FBI volunteer. And that volunteer, every time that phone line rang, the Marge line, that volunteer would pick up that telephone, and answer it, and pose as Marge.
真正的马吉花了数十万美元在虚假的奖品促销、投资、金币等等上面。所以联邦调查局找到马吉说，我们真的认为我们需要没收你的电话号码，因为它正在被用来毁掉你的生活。一旦马吉同意了这一点，她的电话号码就被安装在了一名联邦调查局志愿者家里。而那名志愿者，每次那条电话线响起，那条马吉专线，志愿者就会拿起电话，接听，并伪装成马吉。
Marge?
马吉？
Yes?
是的？
It's David Diamond, how are you?
我是大卫·戴安德，你好吗？
Oh, I'm OK. It's kind of warm here.
哦，我还好。这里天气有点暖和。
Yeah. I set you up a video and a package.
是的。我给你准备了一个视频和包裹。
Yes, I have it.
是的，我收到了。
OK. The video is with regard to Mark Erickson. Mark Erickson is the person who is heading up the program. And he is very successful in taking upstart companies and making them successful. You've probably heard of Hard Copy. He's the original producer of Hard Copy.
好的。视频是关于马克·埃里克森的。马克·埃里克森是负责该项目的人。他在让初创公司取得成功方面非常成功。你可能听说过《硬拷贝》节目。他是《硬拷贝》的原制片人。
I've heard of it, yes.
我听说过，是的。
OK.
好的。
You're smiling as you listen to this. What are you smiling about?
你听这些的时候在笑。你在笑什么？
Well I'm smiling because it's been a while since I've heard Marge, and she sounds so old, and so fragile, and such an easy mark, when in fact she's this sharp FBI informant. She doesn't look as old as she sounds, trust me. So that's one aspect of it. The other aspect is this whole Mark Erickson thing.
嗯，我在笑，因为我已经很久没听到马吉的声音了，她听起来那么苍老，那么脆弱，是一个多么容易上钩的受害者，而事实上她却是这个精明的联邦调查局线人。相信我，她看起来没听起来那么老。所以这是其中的一个方面。另一个方面是这个马克·埃里克森的事情。
Yeah, is he a real person?
是的，他是真人吗？
Mark Erickson is a real person. He was named in our lawsuit.
马克·埃里克森是真人。他在我们的诉讼中被点名了。
And was he an original producer of Hard Copy?
他是《硬拷贝》的原制片人吗？
No. He was a segment producer and on the air reporter for Hard Copy for a brief period of time.
不是。他在《硬拷贝》工作过一小段时间，担任片段制片人和出镜记者。
And is this sort of typical of the cons in the tapes that you've heard, that they'll try to associate what they're selling with a legitimate business or organization or television show, something that people have heard of.
这是否是你在录音中听到的那种骗局的典型手法，即他们会试图将他们销售的东西与合法的企业、组织或电视节目联系起来，也就是人们听说过的东西。
Exactly. They want to make this something people can relate to.
完全正确。他们想让这成为人们能产生共鸣的东西。
Here's the thing. You have to invest everything you've got, or do nothing at all. And I'll say that again. You should invest everything you have. You should transfer all of your investments into this program or do nothing. It doesn't make sense to do just a little bit. You should think about doing a million dollars in this program.
这就是重点。你要么投资你所有的一切，要么什么都别做。我会再说一遍。你应该投资你所拥有的一切。你应该把你所有的投资转入这个项目，或者什么都别做。只投入一点点没意义。你应该考虑在这个项目中投入一百万美元。
Oh. I don't know. That's a lot of money.
哦。我不知道。那是很多钱。
You need to liquidate every nickel you've got. You either want to be in this situation, you either want to be in the situation wholeheartedly and upgrade your investments, or you don't. My suggestion to you is just do the whole thing.
你需要清算你所拥有的每一分钱。你要么想处于这种情况，要么全心全意地加入并升级你的投资，要么就别做。我对你的建议是做全部。
Well, I would never liquidate everything I have.
嗯，我永远不会清算我拥有的一切。
My question is, why not?
我的问题是，为什么不？
Because there's always gambles in anything like this.
因为任何像这样的事情总是有赌博成分。
Anything like what?
像什么样的？
Well, any investment like this.
嗯，任何像这样的投资。
Like this? What does that mean?
像这样的？那是什么意思？
Well, anything you invest in, there's always a gamble.
嗯，你投资的任何东西，总是有赌博。
Now I want to ask you, you told me once that you thought he sounded nervous on this tape. And in this part where she's saying, you know, an investment like this. And he's sort of questioning her, well, what do you mean like this. I wonder, do you have any sense that he's suspicious that she might know what he's up to. I mean, did they know that volunteers are out there trying to trap them posing as dupes?
现在我想问你，你曾经告诉我，你觉得他在录音中听起来很紧张。在她说“像这样的投资”的这一部分，他质问她“你说的像这样是什么意思”。我想知道，你有没有感觉到他怀疑她可能知道他在搞什么鬼？我的意思是，他们知道外面有志愿者试图通过伪装成受骗者来引诱他们吗？
No. Since we talked about this tape last, I actually had a revelation that came to me as to why. I listened to over 40 individual tapes of David Diamond. Of conversations with Marge and conversations with others over the course of about a year. And one of the things, when you've listen to all of them, you find that David, in the earlier part of that year, was much more sweet and cautious, and trying to bond with these women. And patient. And sometimes would spend an hour on the phone with them. The tape would be an hour long.
不知道。自从我们上次谈论这段录音以来，我实际上有了一个关于为什么的启示。我听了超过40段大卫·戴安德的录音。在这一年左右的时间里，与马吉的对话和其他人的对话。当你听完所有这些之后，你会发现大卫在这一年的早期，要甜言蜜语和谨慎得多，并试图与这些女性建立联系。很有耐心。有时会在电话上和她们聊一个小时。录音会长达一小时。
But this tape was made towards the very end of that year period. Probably within a week or two of our raid. Having gone in on the raid, and searched David Diamond's desk that day, I came to realize that David Diamond was starting to question whether he wanted to do this anymore. He was starting to really have some concerns about--
但这段录音是在那一年接近尾声时录制的。可能在我们突袭前一两周。在突袭行动中进去并搜查了大卫·戴安德的办公桌那天，我开始意识到大卫·戴安德开始质疑他是否还想再做这件事了。他开始真正对——产生了一些担忧。
Moral concerns?
道德上的担忧？
Moral concerns about what they were doing. And I believe that in these last couple of weeks, and it's kind of shown in this tape, he was becoming a little bit desperate. He wanted to make a couple of more big hits, and he just couldn't figure out why this woman wasn't going to write him a check. So he started getting frustrated. And it comes out in his voice.
对他们所做事情的道德担忧。我相信在最后这几周，这段录音也表现了出来，他变得有点绝望了。他想再捞几笔大的，但他就是搞不懂为什么这个女人不给他写支票。所以他开始变得沮丧。这在他的声音里流露出来了。
What evidence did you see that he was starting to have moral qualms about what he was doing?
你看到了什么证据表明他开始对他所做的事情产生道德顾虑？
David had become a born again. There were religious tracts all over his office, and posters on his wall.
大卫成了重生派教徒。他的办公室里到处都是宗教小册子，墙上贴着海报。
Just recently?
是最近吗？
I don't know exactly what the time frame was. We do know that he had given a lot of the money that he had made to his church. And we believe that a lot of that was sort of a self-imposed penance, that he can justify what he was doing because he was giving his tithings. This money that he was taking from these poor victims into his church.
我不知道具体的时间框架。我们确实知道他把自己赚来的很多钱捐给了他的教堂。我们认为这在某种程度上是一种自我强加的忏悔，他可以通过因为他进行了什一奉献来为自己的行为辩护。他从这些可怜的受害者那里拿来的钱捐给了他的教堂。
If $30,000 is what you made on every $5,000, and you put $50,000 into this program, that's $300,000 return. That's why I'm telling you, you need to do a million dollars in this program.
如果你每5000美元能赚到3万美元，而你投入5万美元到这个项目中，那就是30万美元的回报。这就是为什么我告诉你，你需要在这个项目中投入一百万美元。
I don't know. I would never put that much in, in any program.
我不知道。我永远不会在任何项目中投入那么多钱。
Do you have an obligation to yourself as an investor to make the most amount of money possible?
作为一个投资者，你是否有义务去赚取尽可能多的钱？
Well, you know, at my age it's really not that-- what do I want to say-- I have enough to live on for the rest of my life.
嗯，你知道，在我的年龄，这真的不是——我该怎么说——我有足够的钱过完余生。
I understand. But is it still in your best interest to make the most amount of money possible if you can find to do it as safely as possible.
我理解。但如果你能找到尽可能安全地做这件事的方法，尽可能多赚钱是否仍然符合你的最大利益？
It's my obligation not to lose what I have.
我有义务不失去我所拥有的。
Correct. But it's also your obligation to keep your money working for you, otherwise, what's the point.
正确。但你也有义务让你的钱为你工作，否则，那样做的意义是什么。
When I heard this part of the tape, even though I knew that this woman, this particular woman, was not getting conned. That she was, in fact, conning him and trapping him, I started to get so angry. Because I was thinking, he is really trying to take all of this old woman's money. All of it. She's saying, I have enough to live on. He's saying, you have an obligation to make more. Do you ever hear things like that and just get angry, even though you know that she's in on the con, on the joke?
当我听到录音的这一部分时，尽管我知道这个女人，这个特定的女人，并没有被骗。事实上，她在欺骗他，困住他，我开始变得非常愤怒。因为我在想，他真的在试图拿走这个老妇人的所有钱。全部。她说，我有足够的钱过日子。他说，你有义务赚更多。你有没有听到过这样的事情，即使你知道她在参与这个骗局，参与这个玩笑，仍然会感到愤怒？
Every time I hear these pitches I'm outraged. Because I am the person that spoke to people who really did send David Diamond tens of thousands of dollars that consisted of their life savings and now don't have any money, even to buy groceries. I've interviewed them. I've seen them sob. Yeah, it makes me very angry.
每次我听到这些推销话术，我都会感到愤怒。因为我是那个与真正给大卫·戴安德寄去数万美元的人交谈过的人，这些钱是他们的积蓄，现在他们连买杂货的钱都没有了。我采访过他们。我看着他们啜泣。是的，这让我非常愤怒。
And what sort of recourse do they have?
他们有什么追索权吗？
Slim and none. Slim and none.
微乎其微。微乎其微。
We have public companies that want to take you public. So if you've got a public company that's passed judgement on it, it's not even me talking anymore. If Mark Erickson wants to do business with you it's not even me talking anymore. You have the ability to make an absolute fortune, and it doesn't make sense not to have every nickel you've got in this particular program. That's why I said it's an emergency investment situation and you should do at least fifty to a hundred, a hundred and fifty units while you have the opportunity.
我们有想让你上市的上市公司。所以如果你有一家上市公司对其进行了评判，那甚至不需要我再说话了。如果马克·埃里克森想和你做生意，那甚至不需要我再说话了。你有能力赚取一笔绝对的财富，不把你的每一分钱都投入这个特定的项目是不合理的。这就是为什么我说这是一个紧急的投资情况，你应该在有机会的时候至少做五十到一百，一百五十个单位。
Well, how much are you investing in this?
嗯，你在这个项目中投资了多少？
I'm not investing anything in this. My investment comes in the time that I put with my clients. Right. And the fact that when they make money, they reinvest with me.
我没有在其中投资任何东西。我的投资体现在我为客户花费的时间上。没错。而且事实是，当他们赚钱时，他们会和我一起重新投资。
Right.
没错。
That's the whole point.
这就是全部意义所在。
You were smiling again. When she said how much are you investing. Is she just screwing around with him?
你又在笑了。当她说你投资了多少时。她是在耍他吗？
Of course, she's playing with him. Yeah. I mean, she's trained to ask him those kinds of questions so that he responds with a misrepresentation.
当然，她在逗他。我的意思是，她受过训练，问他这类问题，这样他就会做出虚假的陈述。
But that doesn't sound like it's part of the script. That just sounds like her being mean in sort of a delicious way.
但这听起来不像是剧本的一部分。这听起来只是她以一种美妙的方式在刻薄他。
Well, no. I think what we were trying to do, or her handler was trying to do, was get her to get him to say, oh yeah, I'm in it, and I've got my mother and my grandmother in it. And I'm putting away money for my child's education with it. Because then we could show later that he hadn't.
嗯，不。我想我们试图做的是，或者她的处理人员试图做的是，让她让他说，哦是的，我投了，我让我母亲和祖母也投了。我正用它为我孩子的教育存钱。因为那样我们稍后就能证明他没有。
Did you ever talk to Marge about what it's like to do this. Do they ever sort of have fun, just thinking, I'm just turning the tables on this guy. He has no idea.
你有没有和马吉谈过做这件事是什么感觉。他们有没有以此为乐，只是想，我只是在这个家伙身上反转了局面。他完全不知道。
I wish I could answer the question. I've never spoken to them. I'd love to get the answer to that myself. I'd like to ask that question myself. I think they get a lot of personal satisfaction though.
我希望我能回答这个问题。我从未和他们交谈过。我也很想自己得到答案。我想亲自问这个问题。不过，我认为他们获得了很大的个人满足感。
How often do you get a chance to catch a bad guy as just a regular civilian.
作为一个普通平民，你有多少机会抓到一个坏蛋。
Yeah, exactly. I do it too, I tape people using an alias in cases that I work.
是的，没错。我也做，我在工作中处理案件时会使用化名录音。
And is it fun?
那很有趣吗？
I love it. I love to get these people to tell me stuff. It's like acting. There's a rush.
我喜欢它。我喜欢让这些人告诉我事情。就像演戏一样。有一种冲动感。
The rush of a con, the pleasure of it, is knowing that you have more power than the person you're conning. You know more. You know that it's a con. And let's face it, given the choice between being the mark and being the con man, nobody's going to choose to be the mark. But the problem is, the more confidence you have in your own con, the more easily you become a mark yourself. Con men get taken by other con men all the time. There just seems to be something about the particular arrogance of always being on the knowing side of the con that makes for a really, really good mark.
骗局的冲动，它的乐趣，在于知道你比你正在欺骗的人拥有更多的权力。你知道更多。你知道这是一个骗局。说实话，在成为受害者和成为骗子之间做出选择时，没人会选择成为受害者。但问题是，你对自己的骗局越有信心，你就越容易成为受害者。骗子总是被其他骗子欺骗。总是站在骗局的知情一方，这种特定的傲慢似乎使得人们成为一个非常、非常好的受害者目标。
Nancy Updike, in Los Angeles. Coming up, the thrill of sitting close to the stage, and the evil that that can lead to. In a minute, for Public Radio International, when our program continues.
洛杉矶的南希·厄普代克。接下来，坐在舞台附近的快感，以及这可能导致的邪恶。一分钟后，为了国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, pulling a hoax on yourself. Stories of people who think that they are fooling others until they're not anymore.
这是《这就是美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周在节目中都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种不同的相关故事。今天的节目，对自己进行欺骗。关于那些认为自己在愚弄别人，直到他们不再愚弄别人的故事。
We've arrived at act three of our program. Act three, Outperforming the Performers. It's a measure of just how hungry people are to create a community that a full fledged, tight knit group of friends could form out of a publicity stunt. Back in 1996, a new musical called Rent was moving from a small theater in New York's East Village to the big time, a Broadway house just a half block from Times Square. The show presented a romanticized view of what it means to be young and broke.
我们已经到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，《超越表演者》。人们建立社区的渴望程度是一个衡量标准，一个成熟、紧密的友谊群体竟然可以源于一个宣传噱头。回到1996年，一部名为《吉屋出租》的新音乐剧正在从纽约东村的一个小剧院搬到大舞台，一个距离时代广场仅半个街区的百老汇剧院。该剧呈现了一种浪漫化的视角，描绘了年轻且贫穷意味着什么。
And to keep the magical air of youth and poverty in the house, the producers decided that every single night they would sell two rows of seats, the first two rows, some of the best seats in the house, for a price nearly anyone could scrape together. $20 a pop, less than a third of what tickets normally sell for on Broadway. Hundreds of teens and twenty somethings took the bait. So many, that if you wanted to get one of the cheap seats, you had to arrive at six o'clock a night before, get in line with a sleeping bag, and stay out all night.
为了保持剧院中那充满青春和贫穷的魔幻氛围，制片人决定每晚卖两排座位，前两排，剧院中最好的座位，价格几乎任何人都能凑出来。每张20美元，不到百老汇正常票价的三分之一。数百名十几岁和二十几岁的年轻人上钩了。人数之多，如果你想买到一张廉价票，你必须在前一晚六点到达，带着睡袋排队，在外面待上一整晚。
See where they're standing? That's where we used to sleep.
看到他们站的地方了吗？那就是我们以前睡觉的地方。
We would sleep all where those photos are.
我们就睡在那些照片所在的所有地方。
Joe Gillis and Rebecca Allen stand in front of the theater where Rent is still playing, near a row of life-sized pictures of the cast, mounted on a wall by the theater door.
乔·吉利斯和丽贝卡·艾伦站在剧院前，那里还在演《吉屋出租》，靠近剧院门边墙上安装的一排真人大小的演员照片。
During the show we had to stay out there because they had to keep the marquee area clear.
演出期间我们必须待在外面，因为他们必须保持天幕区域清洁。
So as soon as the show was over and they closed the doors, we'd all run over, and we all like, claim our spot because we'd all want to sleep under our favorite cast member.
所以演出一结束，他们关上门，我们就会跑过去，我们都会像这样，认领我们的位置，因为我们都想睡在我们最喜欢的演员下方。
And so which one was yours?
那么你是哪一个？
I slept under Daphne once and I think I slept under Anthony another time.
我有一次睡在达芙妮下面，我想另一次我睡在安东尼下面。
You're sleeping on the pavement while people walk by, ignoring you. And you're like, yeah, I'm just like those people in the play. You don't really think that.
你睡在人行道上，路人走过，无视你。然后你就像，是的，我就像剧中的那些人一样。你并不是真的那么想。
But a small part of you thinks that.
但你内心的一小部分会这么想。
A small part of you thinks that. And will identify more with the play, the more you can be like it.
你内心的一小部分会这么想。而且你会越像它，就越认同这部剧。
When they were in line, everybody would hang out all day. Grab some food at McDonald's or at the diner across the street. And the fans who didn't show up at the theater on any given day would communicate through an email list with hundreds of Rent heads on it. Most of them were suburban kids like Joe and Rebecca. Students. Joe says that he was closer to the Rent fans than to his friends back in high school. It was on the Rent line that he first came out as gay, long before his friends back home knew. For lots of teenagers, this was the first community that felt like their own.
排队时，大家整天都会待在一起。在麦当劳或街对面的餐馆吃点东西。那些没有去剧院的粉丝会通过一个有数百名《吉屋出租》粉丝的电子邮件列表进行交流。他们大多数是像乔和丽贝卡那样的郊区孩子。学生。乔说他与《吉屋出租》粉丝的关系比他在高中的朋友更亲密。就是在排队买票时，他第一次公开了自己是同性恋，远在老家的朋友知道之前。对于许多青少年来说，这是第一个让他们感到归属的社区。
It's easy to see why they like the show which unironically celebrates what it unironically calls the bohemian life, in French. A life of poverty and love and art. The setting is contemporary New York. The characters are homosexuals, homeless people, interracial couples, drug addicts, flailing artists, and doomed HIV positive lovers. The mood of the show is at once fantastically idealistic and desperately tragic. Several characters are dying of AIDS. And among the throngs of young people who are drawn to the magnetic pool of Rent's message that you should live each day like it's your only day on Earth was a young student who we'll call Stephanie. All of our interviewees also agreed to call her Stephanie.
很容易理解他们为什么喜欢这部剧，它毫不讽刺地庆祝着它毫不讽刺地称为“波西米亚生活”的生活方式。一种贫穷、爱与艺术的生活。背景是现代纽约。角色是同性恋、无家可归者、跨种族情侣、吸毒者、挣扎的艺术家，以及注定感染艾滋病的恋人。这部剧的情绪既极其理想主义，又极其悲惨。几个角色死于艾滋病。在那些被《吉屋出租》关于“你应该把每一天都当作你在地球上的最后一天”的信息所吸引的年轻人群中，有一位年轻的学生，我们称之为斯蒂芬妮。我们所有的受访者也都同意称她为斯蒂芬妮。
We met about two and a half, three years ago, when we were both interested in the musical Rent. We belonged to the same mailing list online. And she drove up to New York with some friends from college and they stayed in my apartment while they went to see the show.
我们大概两年前，两年前半相识，那时我们都对音乐剧《吉屋出租》感兴趣。我们属于同一个在线邮件列表。她和几个大学的朋友开车去纽约，在看戏期间住在我公寓里。
This is Catherine Skidmore, a friend of Stephanie's and one of the ringleaders among the Rent fans. She was a founder of one of the big internet mailing lists about the show. She's young, used to run in computer hacker circles. One of her tattoos is her social security number in binary code. Now she works for a web start up. Stephanie was one of the many people she got to know, back during the heyday of Rent.
这是凯瑟琳·斯基德莫尔，斯蒂芬妮的朋友，也是《吉屋出租》粉丝中的核心人物之一。她是关于该剧的大型互联网邮件列表的创始人之一。她很年轻，以前在电脑黑客圈子里混过。她的纹身之一是她用二进制代码写的社会安全号码。现在她为一家网络创业公司工作。斯蒂芬妮是她在《吉屋出租》全盛时期结识的众多人之一。
I lived the closest to the theater out of anybody. And I think I was the only person in the line who had her own apartment, so I used to let friends stay with me when they drove up.
我住得离剧院最近。我想我是排队的人里唯一有自己公寓的，所以我经常让朋友开车上来时住在我那儿。
How often would you let somebody stay with you?
你多久会让别人住你那儿一次？
I think every weekend or every other weekend. It got turned into the hotel Catherine.
我想每个周末或隔周一次。它变成了“凯瑟琳酒店”。
She says Stephanie let everyone know that she had a medical condition called autonomic neuropathy. And she said it was terminal. She told this people on the line and she told it to members of the cast of Rent.
她说斯蒂芬妮让所有人都知道她患有一种叫自主神经病变的疾病。她说那是绝症。她告诉了排队的人，也告诉了《吉屋出租》的演员们。
When she was in New York she used to come to the stage door and ask the actors to give her tours backstage, or ask them out for lunch or dinner. When she would email us Stephanie would say, I'm not feeling great. Could you ask the cast to send me a card, could you ask them to email me.
她在纽约时，经常去后台入口要求演员带她参观后台，或者约他们出去吃午饭或晚饭。当她给我们发电子邮件时，斯蒂芬妮会说，“我感觉不太好。你能请演员们给我发张卡片吗，你能请他们给我发邮件吗？”
I first got a letter that she kind of sent the same letter to several of us in the cast in New York.
我最初收到了一封信，她基本上把同样的信发给了我们在纽约的几位演员。
Anthony Rapp played the lead role in Rent.
安东尼·拉普在《吉屋出租》中担任主角。
She was a young aspiring actress, student who was suffering from an illness, and that the show brought her great comfort. And she didn't know how long she had to live. You know, my heart went out to her, as all of our hearts did.
她是一位有抱负的年轻女演员，一个患有疾病的学生，这部剧带给了她极大的安慰。她不知道自己还能活多久。你知道，我的心向她敞开了，就像我们所有人的心一样。
You know, my heart just went out to her. It really did.
你知道，我的心只是向她敞开了。真的。
Gwen Stewart was another cast member.
格温·斯图尔特是另一位演员。
And whenever she came to the show I would make sure that I would try to spend a little time with her. We'd gone out to dinner a couple times, and we'd sit around and talk, and I called her on the phone. I gave her my home number. And it was to the point where I literally made a point of praying for this girl each and every night.
每当她来看戏时，我都会确保试着花点时间陪她。我们出去吃过几次饭，我们就坐下来聊天，我给她打过电话。我把家里的号码给了她。后来甚至到了我真的特意每晚为这个女孩祈祷的地步。
Well ultimately what we were hearing was that she was about to have this major surgery and that she was very scared about it. And that she came to New York right before she was going to have it. That was when Gwen Stewart and I went to lunch with her.
嗯，最终我们听到的是她即将进行一次大手术，她对此感到非常害怕。她在做手术之前来到了纽约。那时格温·斯图尔特和我去和她吃了午餐。
She said that she was contemplating suicide. And I'm a spiritual person, and I'd gone as far as to look up all these scriptures to support life and to support hope and faith. And I would give them to her and tell her to read her Bible. And a lot of the conversations were like that. And then, you know, if it got a little too heavy, we'd swing it around to Rent.
她说她有自杀的念头。我是一个有信仰的人，我甚至专门去查了所有支持生命、支持希望和信仰的经文。我会把它们给她，告诉她去读圣经。很多对话都是那样的。然后，你知道，如果气氛太沉重，我们就转到《吉屋出租》上去。
And at that lunch she brought out some medical paraphernalia. Like a syringe, and like an IV tube thing. She went off to the bathroom to supposedly administer herself some medication.
在午餐会上，她拿出了一些医疗器械。比如注射器，还有静脉输液管之类的东西。她去洗手间假装给自己用药。
After her lunch with the stars in New York, Stephanie flew back to the city where she was from, where she dropped in on a touring company of Rent which happened to be performing there.
在与纽约的明星们共进午餐后，斯蒂芬妮飞回了她的家乡城市，在那里她意外造访了恰好在那里演出的《吉屋出租》巡回剧团。
She was getting to know them and befriending them and telling them her story and they held a prayer circle for her the night before her supposed surgery.
她开始结识他们并与他们交朋友，告诉他们她的故事，他们在她所谓的“手术”前一晚为她举行了祈祷会。
You mean just backstage at the theater?
你是说就在剧院的后台？
Yeah, she was backstage and she was there with the cast and they held a prayer circle for her.
是的，她在后台，和演员们在一起，他们为她举行了祈祷会。
Perhaps you've already figured out where all this is going. In the end, Stephanie did not turn out of any kind of terminal condition. What's remarkable about her story is how far she was able to push the lie, and how compulsively she did it, almost like it was out of her control to stop herself. As she got sicker, her friends in New York started to get emails from someone named Monica, who claimed to be a friend of Stephanie's.
也许你已经猜到这一切要去向何方了。最终，斯蒂芬妮并没有患上任何绝症。她故事中非凡之处在于她能把谎言推到什么地步，以及她有多么强迫性地这样做，几乎到了她无法控制自己停止的地步。随着她“病情”加重，她在纽约的朋友开始收到一个叫莫妮卡的人发来的电子邮件，声称是斯蒂芬妮的朋友。
It was Monica who wrote them when Stephanie went into surgery. Monica gave lengthy accounts of Stephanie's condition, and urged them to organize get well cards and calls from the cast. Catherine later collected all of Monica's and Stephanie's emails into a massive document that she calls the log of deception. With her roommate Jen Eldridge, who also met Stephanie on the Rent line and considered her a close friend, Catherine stood at her computer and scrolled through the log.
当斯蒂芬妮进入手术室时，正是莫妮卡写信给他们。莫妮卡提供了关于斯蒂芬妮病情的详细说明，并敦促他们组织演员们送上慰问卡片和电话。凯瑟琳后来把莫妮卡和斯蒂芬妮的所有邮件收集成了一份庞大的文件，她称之为“欺骗日志”。和她的室友简·埃尔德里奇——简也在排队时遇到了斯蒂芬妮，并认为她是好朋友——凯瑟琳站在电脑前浏览这本日志。
Yeah, oh, where's my favorite one. Yeah, Monica emails are good.
是的，哦，我最喜欢的那条在哪。是的，莫妮卡的邮件很棒。
Find the one about the coma. That's [INTERPOSING VOICES]
找找关于昏迷的那条。那是 [交叉声音]
The suicide one.
自杀的那条。
The suicide one's good, too. There's coma and suicide.
自杀的那条也很棒。有昏迷也有自杀。
They decide to go for suicide.
她们决定看自杀的那条。
Here we go. This is an email from Monica on Friday, November 7, 1997, at 9:00 PM. Where she says, she sent this directly to me. I'm at Stephanie's, I just followed the EMTs out to the ambulance. Stephanie tried to end it all tonight. I found a syringe and an empty container of morphine. She didn't know that I was coming to check on her, blah, blah, blah, they say she'll be OK, and I caught her just in time. She really went all out, and I don't know how much of this she planned or how much--
就是这儿。这是一封莫妮卡在1997年11月7日星期五晚上9点发来的邮件。她说，她直接发给我的。“我在斯蒂芬妮这儿，我刚跟着急救人员去了救护车。斯蒂芬妮今晚试图结束一切。我发现了一支注射器和一个空的吗啡容器。她不知道我会过来检查她，巴拉巴拉，他们说她会没事的，我及时发现并救了她。”她真的做了全套，我不知道她计划了多少，或者有多少——
And keep in mind, this is a weekend she knew that all of her friends were converging in New York at Catherine's apartment. Like we were all going to be there together when this email came. And I think we were all in different levels of transit when you got this email and started just being very upset. And trying to get contact, and everybody's in cars and on trains trying to get there.
记住，这个周末她知道她所有的朋友都汇聚在纽约凯瑟琳的公寓里。就像我们大家都要在一起时，收到了这封邮件。我想我们收到这封邮件并开始感到非常不安时，我们都在不同的交通工具上。大家都在车里和火车上试图赶过去。
And then what happen once you all knew that she was--
那么当你们都知道她——之后发生了什么？
We tried to call the hospitals, and we tried to call 911 to see if they had a record of it. I called Kenny.
我们试着打给医院，我们试着打911看看他们是否有记录。我打给肯尼。
Oh, you tried to call her in a hospital and you couldn't find her.
哦，你试着在医院找她，却找不到。
We could find her. No hospitals in her area had records of her being checked in. So we just said, oh my god, she's somewhere and we can't get to her, and we don't know what to do. And nobody knew what to do.
找不到。她所在地区的医院都没有她入院的记录。所以我们就说，天哪，她在某处，我们联系不到她，不知道该怎么办。没人知道该怎么办。
It's amazing how un-thought out it is. What did she think you were going to do once you got that email?
这简直太没经过深思熟虑了。她以为你们收到那封邮件后会做什么？
I don't know.
我不知道。
And so your evening together, like where all of you were going to be together hanging out, ended up being completely--
所以你们在一起度过的那个晚上，就像你们大家本该聚在一起玩的时候，最后完全——
It was pretty miserable. Yeah, it was really miserable. We went, I guess we saw the show. Everybody bawled their way through it and cried their way through it. And went and told the cast members, of course, because that's what we thought she'd want us to do.
那真是很惨。是的，真的很惨。我想我们去看了演出。每个人都在看戏过程中泪流满面，哭着看完的。当然，我们去告诉了演员们，因为我们以为那是她希望我们做的。
There was one person who always got Monica's story. Josh Safran, who at the time was boyfriends with the star of Rent, Anthony Rapp. Josh not only doubted that Stephanie was sick, he felt horribly guilty for doubting her. This was his problem in a nutshell, he says. Anthony was all about trusting and loving people. He was all about cynicism and mistrust. Fortunately for him, his friends Sean and Michelle also doubted Stephanie.
有一个人总是能看穿莫妮卡的故事。乔什·萨夫兰，当时是《吉屋出租》明星安东尼·拉普的男朋友。乔什不仅怀疑斯蒂芬妮生病，他还因为怀疑她而感到极度内疚。他说，这就是他问题的症结所在。安东尼满心都是信任和爱别人。他满心都是愤世嫉俗和不信任。幸运的是，他的朋友肖恩和米歇尔也怀疑斯蒂芬妮。
So we were suspicious. We were talking more about it for a few days, but then she goes to the hospital, and she goes into a coma.
所以我们很怀疑。我们讨论了几天，但随后她进了医院，陷入了昏迷。
That is, an email from Monica said Stephanie was in a coma. And when this happened Catherine, who wasn't doubting at all, made a decision.
也就是说，莫妮卡的一封邮件说斯蒂芬妮昏迷了。当这件事发生时，完全不怀疑的凯瑟琳做了一个决定。
I talked to Catherine, and Catherine was like, even though she doesn't want us to go there, even though Stephanie doesn't want any visitors, we're going to go. She's in a coma. We should be there. And I said good. And I said, tell Monica. And as soon as they told Monica, Stephanie woke up. As soon as that happened, Sean and Michelle and I were positive that we got her.
我和凯瑟琳谈过，凯瑟琳说，尽管她不想让我们去，尽管斯蒂芬妮不想有任何访客，我们还是要去看。她昏迷了。我们应该在那儿。我说好。我说，告诉莫妮卡。就在他们告诉莫妮卡之后，斯蒂芬妮醒了。这件事一发生，肖恩、米歇尔和我肯定我们识破她了。
Why? Why, what did that mean to you that she woke up at that moment.
为什么？为什么，她在那一刻醒来对你们意味着什么？
She woke up so they didn't have to come. That was Monica, the way she phrased it in the email was, oh, she's better, you don't have to come. She'd like to see you in a few days. It was so obvious that she was pushing off. So we needed to find a way to make sure.
她醒了，所以他们就不用去了。那是莫妮卡在邮件里的措辞，“哦，她好了，你们不用来了。她过几天想见你们。”很明显，她在推托。所以我们需要找一种方法来确认。
How to make sure. Well, it turns out that we live in a country where, if there's an emergency requiring a plumber or an electrician or a mechanic, people turn to professionals. But when it comes to detective work, deep down, we all believe we're capable of it.
如何确认。嗯，事实证明，我们生活在一个国家，如果出现需要水管工、电工或机械师的紧急情况，人们会求助于专业人士。但当涉及到侦探工作时，在内心深处，我们都认为自己是有能力的。
It really became a crusade. I mean, there were three days where none of us slept. We only worked on this. And that was insane. It's embarrassing to think about it.
这真的成了一场十字军东征。我的意思是，有三天我们都没睡觉。我们只做了这件事。那太疯狂了。想到这事真让人尴尬。
They called dozens of hospitals in the city where Stephanie lived, asking if she was a patient. They researched the disease she supposedly had, they pored over old emails looking for clues. Finally they decided to call the elusive Monica who no one had ever spoken to. It turned out that there was in fact a real Monica who went to school with Stephanie, and after some spade work, they found her real last name.
他们打了几十家斯蒂芬妮所在城市的医院，问她是否是病人。他们研究了她所谓的疾病，他们仔细阅读了旧邮件寻找线索。最后他们决定给那个没人跟她说过话、难以捉摸的莫妮卡打电话。事实证明，确实有一个和斯蒂芬妮一起上学的真实莫妮卡，在做了一些调查工作后，他们找到了她的真实姓氏。
We called information, and there was that number. She existed, she was there, we immediately were like, oh [BLEEP]. This was the moment of crisis where we were running around the apartment, freaking out, thinking we are terrible people. Because if we call this number, and this girl's like yes, Stephanie's in the hospital, but she's much better, then we were terrible, cynical people for-- like, it was everything that is wrong with the world and wrong with us. How could we ever think this. How could we spend so much time on it, how could we be such a horrible person.
我们查了电话号码，确实有那个号码。她确实存在，她就在那儿，我们立刻就想，哦[脏话]。这是危机的时刻，我们在公寓里跑来跑去，吓坏了，认为我们是可怕的人。因为如果我们打了这个号码，这个女孩说“是的，斯蒂芬妮在医院，但她好多了”，那么我们就是可怕的、愤世嫉俗的人——就像，这是世界上所有错误和我们身上所有错误的东西。我们怎么会那样想。我们怎么能花那么多时间在这上面，我们怎么能成为这么可怕的人。
So I called the number, and Monica answered. And I was so nervous. I remember it was in my dingy little kitchen with the plastic countertop, and I was so nervous that I was shaking the plastic countertop, and things were falling all over. And Monica was like, I've heard about you, but there's all this loud noise. So nervous. I said, how's Stephanie? And she said, she's doing better. And I was like, OK, thank you. And I hung up the phone because I didn't want-- I couldn't deal with it. But immediately Michelle, Sean, and I were like, she's doing better, she really is sick. But then we thought, but wait a minute, maybe not.
所以我打了那个号码，莫妮卡接了。我非常紧张。我记得是在我肮脏的小厨房里，台面是塑料的，我紧张得在摇晃那个塑料台面，东西掉了一地。莫妮卡说，“我听说过你，但这里有很大的噪音。”我太紧张了。我说，“斯蒂芬妮怎么样了？”她说，“她好多了。”我说，“好的，谢谢。”然后我挂了电话，因为我不想——我应付不了。但米歇尔、肖恩和我立刻觉得，“她说她好多了，她真的病了。”但后来我们想，“等等，也许没病。”
So they were like, you have to call back. And I'm like, I'm not going to call back. We just found out we're horrible people, she really is ill, blah, blah, blah. So they were like, but she didn't sound concerned, she didn't sound worried, call back. So we waited 10 minutes then I called back and I was like hi, I'm sorry Monica, it's Josh again. Look, when's the last time you saw Stephanie? She said, I saw her in class this morning. And that was it.
所以他们说，“你必须打回去。”我说，“我不打了。我们刚发现我们是可怕的人，她真的病了，巴拉巴拉。”所以他们说，“但她听起来并不担心，她听起来不忧虑，打回去。”所以我们等了10分钟，然后我打了回去，我说：“嗨，抱歉莫妮卡，我是乔什。听着，你上次见斯蒂芬妮是什么时候？”她说：“我今天早上在课上见到她了。”事情就是这样。
They contacted Stephanie, let her know that they had talked to the real Monica. They knew there was no coma. After some hedging, Stephanie finally admitted she wasn't dying. The next week, Catherine used her plane ticket and went to talk to Stephanie in person.
他们联系了斯蒂芬妮，让她知道他们已经和真正的莫妮卡谈过了。他们知道并没有什么昏迷。经过一些闪烁其词，斯蒂芬妮终于承认她并没有快要死了。接下来的星期，凯瑟琳用了她的机票去亲自找斯蒂芬妮谈话。
I had a list compiled of questions from our friends on why she did this, how sick was she, and she basically admitted that she did this as a cry for attention of sorts and it went overboard. And then once she started telling us all of these lies about what was going on she didn't have any way to back out of it. Then she kept going and she didn't feel like she could stop at any point during this.
我整理了一份朋友们的问题清单，问她为什么要这样做，她病得有多重，她基本上承认了她是出于一种寻求关注的方式才这样做的，而且做得过头了。然后一旦她开始编造所有关于发生什么事的谎言，她就无法回头了。然后她继续这样做，在这过程中她觉得自己在任何时候都停不下来。
Stephanie declined a request to be interviewed for this radio story. Jen remembers that before everybody knew the truth about Stephanie, it was a regular thing to get panicky calls from her between midnight and 2:00 AM.
斯蒂芬妮拒绝了接受这个广播故事采访的请求。简记得，在每个人都知道斯蒂芬妮真相之前，半夜两点到凌晨两点接到她的恐慌电话是家常便饭。
She would call me crying in the middle of the night that she was just ready to kill herself, couldn't deal with stuff. And I honestly think that when she called me and said these things, that it was genuine. It was just sort of something that went along with it and we would talk about it when she needed to and needed to be upset and cry. And there were many conversations about how she just didn't know how to deal with it anymore. And as I look back on it and I wonder if some of those I don't know how to deal with it conversations were really about she didn't know how to tell people that she had done this. I think there was a point for her when she realized that this was going to blow up in her face.
她会在半夜哭着打电话给我说她准备自杀，处理不了那些事情。我真的认为当她打电话给我说这些时，那是真诚的。这只是伴随它而来的一部分，我们需要时就会谈论它，需要心烦和哭泣时就会谈论。有过很多对话关于她只是不知道如何处理它了。回想起来，我想知道那些“我不知道如何处理它”的对话是否真的是关于她不知道如何告诉人们她做了这些。我觉得对她来说有一个时刻，她意识到这会让她自己陷入麻烦。
A word now about the plot of the musical Rent. It is, of course, about terminal illness. One character dies, another nearly dies. Anthony Rapp.
现在说一下音乐剧《吉屋出租》的剧情。当然，它是关于绝症的。一个角色死了，另一个差点死了。安东尼·拉普。
It's very much about what people do in the face of all that. And in the case of the show, the group of friends really bands together. And so I don't know. I guess maybe on some level Stephanie thought that we would appreciate the plight of somebody who was young and facing something dire like that.
它非常关于人们在面对所有这些时会做什么。在这部剧的例子中，朋友们真的团结在了一起。所以我不确定。我想也许在某种程度上，斯蒂芬妮认为我们会同情一个年轻人面临那种严重情况的困境。
And then everybody would band around.
然后每个人都会团结起来。
Yeah.
是的。
In a way it's like she's casting herself in the show.
在某种程度上，就像她把自己投射到了剧里一样。
Yeah, sure.
是的，当然。
In a way, it's like, what does a fan want from a show. Especially the kind of fan who comes back again and again. It's like somehow they want to get closer to it. They want to get inside it. They want to be in it.
在某种程度上，就像，粉丝想从剧中得到什么。尤其是那种一遍又一遍回来的粉丝。就像他们想以某种方式更接近它。他们想进入它。他们想身处其中。
I know when I see a show that I love, I want to be in it. Seriously. It brought out the best in people. It did.
我知道当我看到一部我喜爱的剧时，我想身处其中。说真的。它激发了人们最好的一面。确实如此。
In fact, the script of the show provided a model for everyone on how to act with Stephanie. Both for the fans who saw the show dozens of times and the cast who sung out their hearts every night about the importance of sticking by your friends when they're dying. Stephanie got her wish. Not only did she get sympathy and attention, she got it from the very people who she watched on stage, in Rent, time and again. When Catherine went back through her old emails, she noticed how often Stephanie was asking to deliver a message to the cast, or asking about the cast.
事实上，该剧的剧本为每个人提供了如何对待斯蒂芬妮的榜样。无论是对看了几十遍的粉丝，还是对每晚在舞台上唱出他们对朋友临终时陪伴的重要性的演员来说。斯蒂芬妮如愿以偿了。她不仅得到了同情和关注，还得到了她一遍又一遍在《吉屋出租》中观看的那些人给予的。当凯瑟琳回顾她的旧邮件时，她注意到斯蒂芬妮是多么频繁地要求向演员传递信息，或者询问关于演员的情况。
Afterwards, it was just pretty sick to read back and see it. That she really didn't care about her-- we thought we were her friends. She really cared more about the cast and their reaction.
后来，回读这些真的很令人作呕。她根本不在乎她的——我们以为我们是她的朋友。她真的更在乎演员和他们的反应。
You know the point in the show where Angel dies and then all the other characters come forward and give little tributes.
你知道剧中天使死的时候，然后所有其他角色上前进行一点致敬的那一段吗。
Yeah, a eulogy.
是的，葬礼演讲。
Give little eulogies. Do you think that Stephanie fantasized about all of you-- you do.
进行小小的悼词。你认为斯蒂芬妮幻想过你们所有人——你是这么想的。
Oh, absolutely. She had emailed us and said, when I go, when they put me in the ground, I want so and so to sing the reprise of "I'll Cover You" from the show at my grave. It would be great.
哦，绝对。她给我们发过邮件说，“当我走了，当他们把我埋在土里时，我想要某某人在这部剧的重唱部分在我的坟墓前演唱‘我会覆盖你’”。那会很棒。
When I first realized that it was all a lie, I was very angry.
当我第一次意识到这一切都是谎言时，我非常生气。
Again, cast member Gwen Stewart.
演员格温·斯图尔特再次说道。
Very angry. And that's why I didn't speak to any of them. Because I had allowed a bunch of strangers to come into my life and I'd opened my heart to them.
非常生气。这就是为什么我没有和他们任何人说话。因为我让一群陌生人进入了我的生活，我向他们敞开了心扉。
After this, did you change your attitude toward the fans in general?
在那之后，你对粉丝的态度总体上改变了吗？
Not really. I mean, I didn't give out my number anymore. But I still signed autographs. I still took the time to talk to people, and took pictures, and all that other stuff. I didn't open myself anymore like I did. I felt betrayed. And I had to make sure that I didn't allow anybody else to do that.
没有。我的意思是，我不再给号码了。但我仍然签售。我仍然花时间与人交谈，拍照，做所有那些事。我不再像那样敞开心扉了。我感到背叛。我必须确保我没有让其他人那样做。
After all this happened, did you want to pray for her, still.
在这之后，你还想为她祈祷吗。
Oh, I did. I did. Because I realized that sickness and death were the least of her problems.
哦，我有。我有。因为我意识到疾病和死亡是她最轻的问题。
Back on 41st Street, Rebecca and Joe, who knew Stephanie, but not all that well, say that Stephanie was just doing a more extreme version of what a lot of people did on the line.
回到第41街，认识斯蒂芬妮但并不太熟的丽贝卡和乔说，斯蒂芬妮只是在做很多人排队时所做事情的更极端版本。
It's not surprising to find out that something you think about someone in the line is a lie, or just like, a little off. Sasha, please, don't get me started. For example, this is my good friend Joe Gillis. But that is not his name. And how long did I know you before I knew that was not your name.
发现你在排队时认为关于某人的事情是谎言，或者只是稍微有点出入，这并不令人惊讶。萨沙，拜托，别跟我提这个。例如，这是我的好朋友乔·吉利斯。但那不是他的名字。我认识你多久才知道那不是你的名字。
When did you figure out that was not my name?
你什么时候发现那不是我的名字的？
What is your name?
你叫什么名字？
My name is Joe Falduti.
我的名字是乔·法尔杜蒂。
On the line there was a Bridget, whose real name was Laura, a 15-year-old who everybody thought was 22, and many gay teenagers, who are out only on the neutral ground of 41st Street.
在队伍里有个布里奇特，真名是劳拉，一个大家都以为是22岁的15岁女孩，还有许多同性恋青少年，他们只在第41街的中立地带出柜。
I mean, I actively knew it was not real life. And I actually would say, my Rent friends and my real friends. But it's really weird how something that was so not real affected real life so much.
我的意思是，我积极地知道这不是真实生活。我甚至会说，“我的《吉屋出租》朋友和我的现实朋友”。但真的很奇怪，某种完全不真实的东西竟然对真实生活产生了这么大的影响。
In a way, a play does too.
在某种程度上，戏剧也是如此。
That's what theater wants to do. They want you to become emotionally involved and care about something, and then leave it and go back to your real life.
那正是戏剧想要做的。他们想让你在情感上投入并关心某件事，然后离开它，回到你的现实生活中。
Which is what Stephanie did on the Rent line. She got everyone emotionally involved, made them care about something. And then, she went back to her real life.
这就是斯蒂芬妮在《吉屋出租》队伍里所做的。她让每个人都在情感上投入，让他们关心某件事。然后，她回到了她的现实生活中。
Well, our program was produced today by me and Blue Chevigny. With Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and conciliary Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Eric Halvorsten. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Musical help today from one of our listeners who sent us an instrumental CD, Rand Coriega.
好吧，我们的节目今天由我和布鲁·切维尼制作。还有亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、苏珊·伯顿和朱莉·斯奈德。特约编辑：保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。制作帮助：托德·巴赫曼和埃里克·哈尔沃斯滕。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。今天的音乐帮助来自我们的一位听众，他寄给我们一张乐器CD，兰德·科里加。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago. 312-832-3380. Or you know you can order cassettes of our programs or listen online for free at our website, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果您想购买本节目或我们任何节目的盒式磁带，请在芝加哥致电我们WBEZ。312-832-3380。或者您知道，您可以订购我们节目的磁带或在我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org上免费在线收听。《这就是美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS] WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who is not jealous at all of the fact that the This American Life staff gets to tape interviews all the time.
[资助信用] WBEZ管理监督：托里·马拉蒂亚，他一点也不嫉妒《这就是美国生活》的工作人员可以随时录制采访的事实。
You know, I do it too. I tape people using an alias.
你知道，我也做。我用化名录音。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《这就是美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。